ยินดีต้อนรับกลับมาสู่การทำความเข้าใจข้อมูลควอนตัมและการคำนวณ ผมชื่อ John Watrous และเป็นผู้อำนวยการด้านเทคนิคฝ่ายการศึกษาที่ IBM
Quantum นี่คือบทเรียนที่ 10 ของซีรีส์ และเป็นบทเรียนที่สองในหน่วยที่สาม ซึ่งเกี่ยวกับ
สูตรทั่วไปของข้อมูลควอนตัม บทเรียนนี้เกี่ยวกับ channel ซึ่งแสดงถึงการเปลี่ยนแปลงใน
ระบบที่จัดเก็บข้อมูลควอนตัม รวมถึงการดำเนินการที่มีประโยชน์ เช่น การดำเนินการโดย
unitary gate และ circuit ควอนตัม รวมถึงการเปลี่ยนแปลงที่เราอาจต้องการหลีกเลี่ยง เช่น สัญญาณรบกวน เรายังสามารถอธิบายการวัดผล
ในรูปของ channel ได้ด้วย และนั่นเป็นสิ่งที่เราจะเจาะลึกในบทเรียนถัดไป คำว่า channel มาจาก
ทฤษฎีสารสนเทศ ซึ่งศึกษาเรื่องต่างๆ รวมถึงความสามารถในการรับส่งข้อมูลของการสื่อสาร
ที่มีสัญญาณรบกวน ดังนั้นเวลาที่เราคิดเรื่อง channel เรากำลังคิดแบบนามธรรมเกี่ยวกับ
channel การสื่อสาร อาจดูแปลกๆ ที่จะคิดว่าการคำนวณซับซ้อนเป็น channel การสื่อสาร แต่เราต้องการ
คำเพื่อใช้อ้างถึงแนวคิดทั่วไปของกระบวนการที่เปลี่ยนแปลงข้อมูลในรูปแบบใดรูปแบบหนึ่ง และไม่ว่าจะดีหรือไม่ คำว่า
channel ก็ติดปากไปแล้ว ซึ่งส่วนใหญ่เป็นเพราะผลกระทบมหาศาลที่ทฤษฎีสารสนเทศ และโดยเฉพาะอย่างยิ่ง
ผลงานของ Claude Shannon ในทศวรรษ 1940 ที่มีต่อข้อมูลควอนตัมและการคำนวณ นี่คือภาพรวมของ
บทเรียน เราจะเริ่มจากพื้นฐาน รวมถึงนิยามของ channel ว่าคืออะไร รวมถึงวิธีที่การดำเนินการ unitary ในสูตรแบบย่อ
ของข้อมูลควอนตัมสามารถอธิบายเป็น channel ได้ เราจะพูดถึงข้อเท็จจริงที่ว่าการรวมแบบนูนของ channel ก็เป็น channel เช่นกัน และถ้าสงสัยว่า
ทำไมแนวคิดเรื่องความนูนถึงโผล่มาเรื่อยๆ ก็เพราะมันเป็นแนวคิดทางคณิตศาสตร์ที่สำคัญมากจริงๆ ในทฤษฎีของ
ข้อมูลควอนตัม เราจะได้เห็นตัวอย่างของ channel โดยเฉพาะ qubit channel ซึ่งจะปรากฏขึ้นเรื่อยๆ
ตลอดส่วนที่เหลือของบทเรียน ในส่วนที่สองของบทเรียน เราจะพูดถึงสามวิธีที่แตกต่างกันในการแทน channel
ทางคณิตศาสตร์ โดยเฉพาะเราจะพูดถึง Stinespring representation, Kraus representation และ Choi
representation ซึ่งตั้งชื่อตามสามคนที่งานของพวกเขามีความสำคัญต่อการพัฒนา representation เหล่านี้ และในส่วนที่สาม
ซึ่งเป็นส่วนสุดท้ายของบทเรียน เราจะพูดถึงการพิสูจน์ทางคณิตศาสตร์ที่แสดงว่า representation ทั้งสามนี้เท่ากันจริงๆ รวมถึงข้อเท็จจริงที่ว่า
ทั้งหมดระบุลักษณะของนิยาม channel ได้อย่างถูกต้อง เป็นการพิสูจน์ทางคณิตศาสตร์ที่เจ๋งมากในความเห็นของผม และหวังว่ามันจะช่วยเพิ่มความ
ชัดเจนให้กับ representation ต่างๆ เหล่านี้ ว่ามันเกี่ยวข้องกันอย่างไรและทำงานอย่างไรโดยทั่วไป เราจะเริ่มจากพื้นฐานและ
ตอบคำถามว่า channel คืออะไร อย่างที่บอกไปตอนเริ่มบทเรียน channel อธิบายการเปลี่ยนแปลง
โดยเฉพาะการเปลี่ยนแปลงแบบเวลาไม่ต่อเนื่องในระบบที่จัดเก็บข้อมูลควอนตัม ตรงนี้เมื่อเราพูดถึงการเปลี่ยนแปลง
แบบเวลาไม่ต่อเนื่อง เราแค่คิดถึงการเปลี่ยนแปลงที่เกิดขึ้นระหว่างสองช่วงเวลาที่แตกต่างกัน ตรงข้ามกับ
กระบวนการต่อเนื่อง เช่น ที่สมเหตุสมผลที่จะคิดถึงในช่วงเวลาเล็กๆ มาก channel รวมถึงการดำเนินการที่มีประโยชน์ เช่น
การดำเนินการ unitary ที่ทำโดย gate และ circuit ควอนตัม รวมถึงการเปลี่ยนแปลงจากสัญญาณรบกวน เช่น
สำหรับบทเรียนนี้ เราจะคิดเรื่อง channel ในแง่คณิตศาสตร์เชิงนามธรรมเป็นส่วนใหญ่ และไม่จำเป็นต้อง
แยกแยะว่าอะไรมีประโยชน์และอะไรไม่มี ชื่อทั่วไปของ channel ได้แก่ ตัวอักษรกรีกพิมพ์ใหญ่ ฟี
ไซ และไค และเราจะใช้ตัวอักษรต่างๆ เพื่ออ้างถึง channel เฉพาะบางตัว ในสถานการณ์ง่ายๆ ที่
เรามีระบบที่อยู่ในสถานะที่อธิบายโดยเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่น โร และเราใช้ channel ฟี กับระบบนั้น
ผลลัพธ์คือระบบที่มีสถานะอธิบายโดยเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่น ฟีของโร ดังนั้นเรากำลังคิดว่า
channel ฟี เป็นฟังก์ชันที่ใช้กับเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นขนาดเฉพาะได้ หรือพูดอีกอย่างคือ
เมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นของระบบเฉพาะที่เราใช้ channel นี้ มีข้อกำหนดสองสามข้อที่ channel ต้องเป็นไปตาม เพื่อให้ถือว่า
เป็น channel ที่ถูกต้อง ข้อแรก channel เป็นการแปลงเชิงเส้น นี่คล้ายคลึงอย่างสมบูรณ์กับสถานการณ์ที่เรามีทั้ง
ในสูตรแบบย่อของข้อมูลควอนตัม ที่การดำเนินการบนเวกเตอร์สถานะควอนตัมจำเป็นต้องเป็นเชิงเส้น เช่นเดียวกับ
ในสูตรมาตรฐานของข้อมูลคลาสสิก ที่การดำเนินการเชิงความน่าจะเป็นเป็นเชิงเส้น คุณสามารถตั้งคำถามกับข้อกำหนดพื้นฐาน
ของความเป็นเชิงเส้นนี้ได้ถ้าอยากจริงๆ แต่ถ้าเราต้องการทฤษฎีที่สอดคล้องกับทั้งทฤษฎีความน่าจะเป็น
และการเลือกแทนสถานะควอนตัมด้วยเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่น เราก็ไม่มีทางเลือกจริงๆ และต้องยอมรับว่า channel เป็นเชิงเส้น
ข้อกำหนดที่สองคือ channel แปลงเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นเป็นเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่น นั่นสมเหตุสมผลมาก เพราะถ้าเราเลือกแทน
สถานะของระบบด้วยเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่น และเราใช้ channel กับระบบที่อยู่ในสถานะใดสถานะหนึ่ง ผลลัพธ์ต้องเป็นสถานะที่ถูกต้อง และดังนั้น
แทนด้วยเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่น มีจุดสำคัญมากที่ต้องเพิ่มตรงนี้ นั่นคือข้อกำหนดนี้
ต้องเป็นจริงไม่เฉพาะเมื่อเราใช้ channel กับระบบที่แยกตัวซึ่งสถานะอธิบายโดยเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่น
แต่ยังรวมถึงเมื่อเรามีระบบประกอบที่สถานะอธิบายโดยเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่น และเราใช้ channel กับแค่
บางส่วนของระบบนั้น นั่นคือข้อกำหนดที่เราวางไว้สำหรับ channel และเราจะเห็นว่ามันคล้ายคลึงกันมาก
กับข้อกำหนดที่เรามีสำหรับการดำเนินการทั้งในสูตรแบบย่อของข้อมูลควอนตัมและสูตรมาตรฐาน
ของข้อมูลคลาสสิก ในสูตรแบบย่อของข้อมูลควอนตัม การดำเนินการแทนด้วยเมทริกซ์ unitary เพราะ
มันตรงกับการแปลงเชิงเส้นที่แปลงเวกเตอร์สถานะควอนตัมเป็นเวกเตอร์สถานะควอนตัมเสมอ สำหรับ
ระบบที่กำหนด และเช่นเดียวกัน การดำเนินการเชิงความน่าจะเป็นแทนด้วยเมทริกซ์สุ่ม เพราะนั่นคือตัวที่
แปลงเวกเตอร์ความน่าจะเป็นเป็นเวกเตอร์ความน่าจะเป็นเสมอ ตรงนี้เราทำงานกับเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่น และมี
ข้อกำหนดเพิ่มเติมเกี่ยวกับระบบประกอบ ซึ่งไม่จำเป็นสำหรับเวกเตอร์สถานะควอนตัม
หรือเวกเตอร์ความน่าจะเป็น แต่นอกเหนือจากนั้น ข้อกำหนดก็คล้ายคลึงกัน และในแง่หนึ่งถูกบังคับโดยการเลือก
แทนสถานะควอนตัมด้วยเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่น นี่คือรายละเอียดเพิ่มเติมเกี่ยวกับ channel รวมถึงธรรมเนียม
ว่าเราจะคิดเรื่องระบบอินพุตและเอาต์พุตของ channel ตลอดบทเรียนอย่างไร รวมถึงรายละเอียดเพิ่มเติม
เกี่ยวกับข้อกำหนดที่ channel แปลงเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นเป็นเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นเสมอ อันดับแรก channel ทุกตัว
สมมติว่ามีระบบอินพุตและระบบเอาต์พุต เราสามารถตั้งชื่อระบบเหล่านี้ได้ตามต้องการ แต่ตลอดบทเรียนนี้
ผมจะใช้ชื่อ X สำหรับระบบอินพุต และชื่อ Y สำหรับระบบเอาต์พุต ในเชิงแนวคิด channel
แปลงระบบอินพุตเป็นระบบเอาต์พุต ดังนั้นระบบอินพุตและเอาต์พุตไม่มีอยู่พร้อมกัน เรา
เริ่มจาก X ใช้ channel และผลลัพธ์คือ X ถูกแปลงเป็น Y ซึ่งสถานะถูก
กำหนดโดยการแปลงเชิงเส้นที่เกี่ยวข้องกับ channel ระบบอินพุตและเอาต์พุตของ channel ไม่จำเป็นต้องเหมือนกัน โดยเฉพาะ
ไม่จำเป็นต้องมีจำนวนสถานะคลาสสิกเท่ากัน อย่างไรก็ตาม อาจเป็นไปได้ว่าระบบอินพุตและเอาต์พุตเป็นระบบเดียวกัน หรือพูดอีกอย่าง
X เท่ากับ Y ซึ่งในกรณีนั้นเราแค่จินตนาการว่า ฟี กำลังเปลี่ยนสถานะของระบบ และจริงๆ แล้วนี่
มักจะเป็นสถานการณ์ที่เราสนใจ แต่ความเป็นไปได้นี้สอดคล้องกับจุดแรกในแง่ที่ว่าเราไม่มี
ระบบอินพุตและเอาต์พุตเป็นสองระบบแยกกันในเวลาเดียวกัน และไม่ว่ากรณีใด มันจะสะดวกสำหรับ
จุดประสงค์ของบทเรียนนี้ที่จะใช้ตัวอักษรต่างกัน คือ X และ Y สำหรับระบบอินพุตและเอาต์พุต
แค่เพื่อช่วยให้เราจัดระเบียบได้ ทีนี้มาลงรายละเอียดเพิ่มเติมเกี่ยวกับข้อกำหนดที่ channel แปลงเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่น
เป็นเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นเสมอ สมมติว่าเราแนะนำระบบใหม่ Z เข้ามา
ตั้งชื่อเซตสถานะคลาสสิกของระบบใหม่นี้ว่าแกมมา ลองจินตนาการว่าเราสร้างระบบประกอบใหม่ ZX
ที่ประกอบด้วยระบบใหม่รวมกับระบบอินพุต X ของ channel ฟี และสมมติว่าระบบประกอบนี้
อยู่ในสถานะที่อธิบายโดยเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่น โร นี่อาจเป็นสถานะควอนตัมใดก็ได้ของคู่นี้ แต่ไม่ว่าสถานะอะไร
มันเป็นไปได้เสมอที่จะแสดงเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่น โร ในรูปแบบที่แสดงบนหน้าจอ โดยทั้ง A และ B
ครอบคลุมเซตสถานะคลาสสิกแกมมา และแต่ละ โร AB เป็นเมทริกซ์ที่แถวและคอลัมน์ตรงกับ
เซตสถานะคลาสสิกของ X และเราไม่จำเป็นต้องตั้งชื่อเซตสถานะคลาสสิกนั้นตอนนี้ เพื่อความชัดเจน แต่ละ โร AB ไม่จำเป็นต้องเป็น
เมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นด้วยตัวมันเอง แต่เมทริกซ์ โร ทั้งหมดจำเป็นต้องเป็นเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่น เมื่อเราใช้ channel ฟี กับ
ระบบ X มันถูกแปลงเป็น Y ดังนั้นเราเหลือคู่ ZY และวิธีที่เรากำหนด
สถานะของคู่นี้หลังจากทำ ฟี บนแค่ X คือการประเมินการแปลงเชิงเส้น ฟี บนแต่ละเมทริกซ์ โร A
อีกวิธีในการพูดคือเราหาเทนเซอร์โปรดักต์ของการแปลง ฟี กับการแปลงเอกลักษณ์บนเมทริกซ์จัตุรัสที่มีแถวและคอลัมน์
ตรงกับแกมมา และนั่นก็ตรงกับการไม่ทำอะไรกับระบบใหม่ Z แต่นี่เป็นคำอธิบายที่เท่ากัน
และไม่จำเป็นต้องลงรายละเอียดเกี่ยวกับเทนเซอร์โปรดักต์ของการแปลงในรูปแบบนี้
อย่างไรก็ตาม มันทำงานในลักษณะที่ตรงไปตรงมาคล้ายกับที่ทำงานกับเวกเตอร์และเมทริกซ์ วิธีหนึ่งในการคิดเรื่องนี้ในเชิงภาพคือ
ในรูปของเมทริกซ์บล็อก และถ้าเราสมมติแบบง่ายว่าเซตสถานะคลาสสิกแกมมาประกอบด้วย
จำนวนเต็มระหว่าง 0 ถึง N ลบ 1 สำหรับจำนวนเต็มบวก M ก็จะง่ายที่จะเขียนทั้งหมดนี้ลงไปตามที่
แสดงตรงนี้ และตอนนี้ขอย้ำข้อกำหนดที่เราวางไว้สำหรับ ฟี เพื่อให้เป็น channel ที่ถูกต้อง เราต้องได้เมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่น
จากกระบวนการนี้เสมอ และนี่ต้องเป็นจริงไม่ว่าเราจะเลือกระบบ Z อะไร รวมถึง
การเลือก โร โดยมีเงื่อนไขว่าเป็นเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่น นั่นอาจดูเป็นข้อกำหนดที่เข้มงวดมาก และ
อาจดูเหมือนว่ายากมากที่จะตรวจสอบ แต่อย่างที่เราจะเห็นตอนจบบทเรียน มันไม่ได้เข้มงวด
หรือยากที่จะตรวจสอบขนาดนั้น โดยเฉพาะเรามีลักษณะเฉพาะทางคณิตศาสตร์ที่ดีสำหรับเงื่อนไขนี้
ซึ่งเชื่อมโยงกับ representation ต่างๆ ที่เราจะพูดถึงในภายหลัง ทีนี้มาดูตัวอย่างของ channel กัน
เริ่มจากหมวดหมู่ทั้งหมดของ channel ที่เรียกว่า unitary channel พูดง่ายๆ คือเป็นการดำเนินการ
unitary เหมือนที่เรามีในสูตรแบบย่อของข้อมูลควอนตัม มองในรูปของ channel อย่างแม่นยำ สมมติว่า U เป็นเมทริกซ์
unitary ที่แทนการดำเนินการ unitary บนระบบ X ดังนั้นในสูตรแบบย่อของข้อมูล
ควอนตัม เราจะคูณเมทริกซ์นี้กับเวกเตอร์สถานะควอนตัมที่กำหนดเพื่อกำหนดผลกระทบของการดำเนินการนั้นต่อสถานะควอนตัมนั้น
วิธีที่มันทำงานกับเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นคือเราคูณเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นทางซ้ายด้วย U และทางขวาด้วย U
แด็กเกอร์ ในแง่คณิตศาสตร์เราเรียกการดำเนินการนี้ว่า conjugation โดยเมทริกซ์ U นี่สอดคล้องกับ เคซี
บราไซ ที่เป็นเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นที่อธิบายสถานะที่แทนโดยเวกเตอร์สถานะควอนตัม ไซ และมันค่อนข้าง
ง่ายที่จะตรวจสอบว่า โดยเฉพาะถ้าเราทำ U กับเวกเตอร์สถานะควอนตัม เคไอ เราจะได้ U คูณ เคไอ และ
representation เมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นของมันกำหนดโดยเวกเตอร์นั้นคูณ conjugate transpose ซึ่งคือ U คูณ เคไอ คูณ บราไซ คูณ U
แด็กเกอร์ เมื่อเราหา conjugate transpose ของ U คูณ เคไอ ดังนั้นวิธีที่ channel นี้ถูกกำหนด
สมเหตุสมผลสำหรับสถานะบริสุทธิ์ และเมื่อเรารวมกับความเป็นเชิงเส้น เราจะเห็นว่ามันสมเหตุสมผลสำหรับเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่น
โดยทั่วไป เนื่องจากเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นทุกตัวสามารถแสดงเป็นการรวมแบบนูนของสถานะบริสุทธิ์ได้ นิยาม
นี้ให้ channel ที่ถูกต้องเสมอสำหรับการเลือกการดำเนินการ unitary U ใดก็ได้ โดยเฉพาะการ conjugate ด้วย
เมทริกซ์ unitary แบบนี้ไม่เปลี่ยนเทรซของเมทริกซ์ และถ้าเรา conjugate เมทริกซ์กึ่งบวกแน่นอนใดก็ได้
ด้วยเมทริกซ์ใดก็ได้ เราจะได้เมทริกซ์กึ่งบวกแน่นอนอีกตัว และมันค่อนข้างง่ายที่จะได้มา
โดยตรงจากนิยามของเมทริกซ์กึ่งบวกแน่นอน ดังนั้นเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นถูกแปลงเป็นเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นเสมอ
และทั้งหมดนี้ยังคงจริงแม้ว่าเราจะเทนเซอร์ U กับเมทริกซ์เอกลักษณ์ขนาดใดก็ได้ ซึ่งเท่ากับ
การใช้ channel นี้กับแค่บางส่วนของระบบประกอบ นี่คือตัวอย่างง่ายๆ ของ unitary channel สมมติว่าเรา
ให้ U เป็นเมทริกซ์เอกลักษณ์ นี่เป็น channel ที่ถูกต้องอย่างชัดเจน เรียกว่า identity channel ไม่ทำ
อะไรเลยก็เป็นการดำเนินการเชิงเส้นแน่นอน และถ้าเราเริ่มด้วยเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นแล้วไม่ทำอะไร มัน
ก็ยังเป็นเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นอยู่ นี่จึงเป็น channel ที่ถูกต้อง คนใช้สัญลักษณ์ต่างๆ แทน channel นี้
บางทีก็เป็นสัญลักษณ์เดียวกับที่ใช้สำหรับเมทริกซ์เอกลักษณ์ ซึ่งอาจสับสนนิดหน่อย แต่โดยทั่วไปก็ไม่ ตรงนี้ผมใช้
ตัวอักษร ID ย่อจาก identity เพื่อหลีกเลี่ยงความสับสน และสัญกรณ์นี้ก็ค่อนข้างทั่วไป อาจดูเหมือนเป็น
channel ที่น่าเบื่อมาก แต่ในบริบทของการส่งข้อมูล มันเป็น channel ที่สมบูรณ์แบบจริงๆ ที่
ผู้รับได้สิ่งที่ผู้ส่งส่งมาเป๊ะๆ ซึ่งโดยปกติเป็นสิ่งที่คนต้องการมากที่สุดในบริบทนั้น อีกวิธีที่เราสามารถ
ได้ตัวอย่าง channel มากมายคือการหาการรวมแบบนูนของ channel หรือพูดอีกอย่างคือการเฉลี่ย
เข้าด้วยกัน และข้อเท็จจริงที่ว่าเราทำแบบนี้ได้เป็นแง่มุมสำคัญของ channel เพื่ออธิบายรายละเอียดเพิ่ม สมมติเริ่มจากสอง channel ฟี0 และ ฟี1
พร้อมกับจำนวนจริง P ระหว่าง 0 ถึง 1 และเพื่อความชัดเจน เราสมมติว่าสอง channel นี้มี
ระบบอินพุตเดียวกันคือ X รวมถึงระบบเอาต์พุตเดียวกันคือ Y และตอนนี้ลองคิดว่าจะเกิดอะไรขึ้นถ้าเราตัดสินใจ
ใช้ channel แรก ฟี0 ด้วยความน่าจะเป็น P และอีกกรณีด้วยความน่าจะเป็นที่เหลือ 1 ลบ P เราใช้
channel ที่สอง ฟี1 เช่น อาจสุ่มเลือกบิตด้วยความน่าจะเป็นเหล่านั้น แล้วใช้บิตสุ่มนี้
เพื่อกำหนดว่าจะใช้ channel ไหน เมื่อทำแบบนี้ เราก็เท่ากับใช้ channel ใหม่ที่เราอาจเรียกว่า ไซ
ที่กำหนดโดยการรวมแบบนูนของสอง channel ที่เราเริ่มต้น และเราสามารถแสดงได้ตามที่เขียน
บนหน้าจอ เราสามารถหาการรวมเชิงเส้นของการแปลงเชิงเส้นได้เสมอ แบบนี้ และวิธีที่การรวมเชิงเส้น
ของการแปลงเชิงเส้นถูกกำหนดบนอินพุตที่กำหนด ก็คือเราแค่หาการรวมเชิงเส้นแบบเดียวกันของเอาต์พุต
อาจดูเหมือนเรื่องเล็กน้อย แต่มันสมเหตุสมผล เอาต์พุตที่เราได้จากสถานการณ์สมมตินี้ก็แค่
ค่าเฉลี่ยถ่วงน้ำหนักของเอาต์พุตที่เราจะได้จากสอง channel เดิม อย่างไรก็ตาม นี่เป็น channel ใหม่ และ
ถ้า ฟี0 และ ฟี1 เป็น channel ที่ถูกต้องจริงๆ การแปลงใหม่นี้ก็จะเป็น channel ที่ถูกต้องแน่นอน อีกวิธีในการพูด
ในแง่คณิตศาสตร์คือ เซตของ channel ทั้งหมดจากระบบอินพุตที่กำหนดไปยังระบบเอาต์พุตที่กำหนดนั้น
เป็นเซตนูน และนั่นเป็นสมบัติทางคณิตศาสตร์ที่สำคัญของ channel เราทำแบบนี้ได้กว้างกว่านั้น ถ้าเรามี M channel ฟี0 ถึง ฟี M ลบ 1
พร้อมกับเวกเตอร์ความน่าจะเป็นที่บอกว่าความน่าจะเป็นของแต่ละ channel เป็นเท่าไร เราก็ได้ channel ใหม่โดยการเฉลี่ย channel ตามนั้น
ในแง่หนึ่งนี่เป็นแหล่งที่มาของ channel ใหม่ที่ไม่มีวันหมด เช่น กลุ่มที่เรียกว่า mixed unitary channel คือสิ่งที่
เราได้จากการหาการรวมแบบนูนของ unitary channel นั่นคือถ้าเรามี M เมทริกซ์ unitary U0 ถึง U M ลบ
1 ทั้งหมดมีขนาดเท่ากัน พร้อมกับเวกเตอร์ความน่าจะเป็น ถ้าเราหาค่าเฉลี่ยถ่วงน้ำหนักของ channel
ที่ตรงกับเมทริกซ์ unitary แต่ละตัว ตามที่แสดงบนหน้าจอ เราจะได้ channel และ channel
ที่เขียนได้แบบนี้เรียกว่า mixed unitary channel ไม่ใช่ทุก channel จะเป็น mixed unitary channel เราไม่สามารถได้
ทุก channel ด้วยวิธีนี้ แต่มันก็เจอบ่อยมาก ต่อไปเราจะดูตัวอย่างเฉพาะ
ของ channel ทั้งหมดนี้จะเป็นตัวอย่างของ channel จาก qubit หนึ่งตัวไปยัง qubit หนึ่งตัว ซึ่งเรียกว่า qubit
channel อันแรกเรียกว่า qubit reset channel และแนวคิดคือ channel นี้รีเซ็ต qubit
ไปเป็นสถานะศูนย์ ตรงนี้เราใช้ตัวอักษรกรีกพิมพ์ใหญ่แลมบ์ดาแทน channel นี้ และวิธีจำว่า channel นี้ทำอะไรคือ
คิดถึง Bloch sphere แลมบ์ดาพิมพ์ใหญ่ดูเหมือนลูกศรชี้ขึ้น และสถานะศูนย์อยู่ที่ด้านบนของ Bloch sphere เหมือนกับว่า
มันชี้ไปที่ตำแหน่งของเอาต์พุต วิธีที่กำหนดในแง่คณิตศาสตร์คือ แลมบ์ดาของโร เท่ากับ เทรซของโร คูณ เค0 บรา 0 ดังนั้น
ถ้าเราประเมินมันบนเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่น โร ใดก็ได้ เราจะได้สถานะศูนย์ในรูปเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่น เป็นธรรมดาที่จะสงสัยว่า
ทำไมต้องมีเทรซ เราไม่สามารถกำหนด แลมบ์ดาของโร ให้เป็นแค่ เค0 บรา 0 โดยไม่มีเทรซของโรข้างหน้าได้หรือ
คำตอบคือไม่ได้ channel ต้องเป็นการแปลงเชิงเส้น และมันจะไม่เป็นเชิงเส้นถ้าเราเอาเทรซของโรออก นอกจากนี้ต้องจำว่า
บางทีเราต้องรู้ว่า channel ทำงานอย่างไรในฐานะการแปลงเชิงเส้นบนอินพุตที่ไม่ใช่เมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่น เช่น อย่างที่
เราเห็นก่อนหน้า ถ้าเราอยากรู้ว่า channel ทำอะไรเมื่อเราใช้มันกับระบบประกอบ เราต้อง
ประเมิน channel นั้นบนแต่ละบล็อกของเมทริกซ์บล็อกที่ใหญ่กว่า และถึงแม้เมทริกซ์บล็อกทั้งหมดอาจเป็น
เมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่น แต่ละบล็อกโดยทั่วไปจะไม่เป็น มาดูกันว่า channel นี้ทำอะไรเป๊ะๆ เมื่อเราใช้มัน
กับแค่ส่วนหนึ่งของระบบประกอบ โดยเฉพาะว่ามันทำอะไรเมื่อเราใช้กับ qubit หนึ่งในสองตัวที่
สร้างเป็น ebit อย่างแม่นยำ สมมติว่า A และ B เป็น qubit ที่เป็นคู่อยู่ในสถานะ Bell ฟีพลัส และเราใช้แลมบ์ดา
กับ qubit แรก A เพื่อหาว่าเกิดอะไรขึ้น มาแสดงสถานะฟีพลัสเป็นเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นก่อน และ
เพื่อตัวอย่างนี้ ใช้สัญกรณ์ Dirac ทำ นี่คือสถานะฟีพลัสเป็นเวกเตอร์สถานะควอนตัม และนี่คือสิ่งที่เราได้เมื่อ
คูณเวกเตอร์นี้กับ conjugate transpose ของมัน แล้วกระจายทั้งหมดออก จากนั้นเราใช้ channel กับ qubit แรกและประเมินว่าได้อะไร นี่คือ
แลมบ์ดาที่ใช้กับ qubit แรก และนี่คือสิ่งที่เราได้เมื่อประเมินแต่ละพจน์ เทรซของ เค0 บรา 0 คือ 1
และเทรซของ เค1 บรา 1 ก็เช่นกัน ดังนั้นในสองกรณีนั้น เอาต์พุตของ channel คือ เค0 บรา 0 และนั่นอธิบาย
สองพจน์ในคำตอบ เทรซของ เค0 บรา 1 ในทางกลับกันเท่ากับศูนย์ เช่นเดียวกับเทรซของ เค1 บรา 0
ดังนั้นสองพจน์นั้นประเมินได้ศูนย์ จึงไม่มีส่วนร่วมอะไรกับคำตอบ เราสามารถทำให้ง่ายลง
อีกนิด และสิ่งที่เราได้คือ สถานะศูนย์สำหรับ qubit แรกซึ่งคือ A และสถานะผสมสมบูรณ์สำหรับ
qubit ที่สองซึ่งคือ B สังเกตโดยเฉพาะว่าเราไม่ได้สถานะพลัสสำหรับ B ซึ่งอาจไม่ใช่
การเดาที่แย่ ถ้าเราไม่รู้เรื่องเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นและแค่ดูที่ representation เวกเตอร์สถานะควอนตัมของสถานะ แต่
channel นี้ไม่ได้ทำงานแบบนั้น และไม่มี channel ไหนที่จะทำงานแบบนั้นได้ channel แลมบ์ดาเรียกว่า qubit reset channel แต่
วิธีที่มันทำงานจริงๆ คล้ายกับการโยน qubit อินพุตลงถังขยะแล้วแทนที่ด้วย qubit ใหม่ในสถานะศูนย์ แต่จริงๆ แล้วนี่คือ
qubit channel เดียวที่ให้เอาต์พุตเป็นสถานะศูนย์เสมอ นี่คืออีกตัวอย่างของ qubit channel ที่รู้จักกันในชื่อ
completely dephasing channel ตัวนี้แทนด้วยเดลต้า และวิธีที่มันทำงานคือปล่อยให้
ค่าในแนวทแยงของเมทริกซ์ 2x2 คงอยู่ แล้วทำให้ค่านอกแนวทแยงเป็นศูนย์ เดลต้าเป็นตัวอักษรกรีกที่เทียบเท่ากับ D ใน
ตัวอักษรละติน ซึ่งย่อมาจาก diagonal นั่นเป็นวิธีหนึ่งที่จะจำว่า channel นี้ทำอะไร เราสามารถ
แสดง channel นี้ด้วยสัญกรณ์ Dirac ได้อีกแบบตามที่แสดงบนหน้าจอ และเพื่อความชัดเจน เอาต์พุต
เป็นเมทริกซ์ 2x2 เสมอ ดังนั้นเอาต์พุตศูนย์สองตัวนั้นหมายถึงเมทริกซ์ 2x2 ที่เป็นศูนย์ทั้งหมด เราทำ
แบบนี้บ่อย และเราเคยเห็นก่อนหน้าในซีรีส์นี้ สัญลักษณ์ศูนย์โดยทั่วไปใช้ อาจกำกวมหน่อย เพื่อหมายถึงสมาชิกศูนย์
ของสิ่งที่เรากำลังพูดถึง ไม่ว่าจะเป็นสเกลาร์ เวกเตอร์ เมทริกซ์ หรืออะไรก็ตาม มาทำเหมือนเดิมที่เราทำก่อนหน้ากับ
qubit reset channel และดูว่าเกิดอะไรขึ้นถ้าเราใช้ channel นี้กับครึ่งหนึ่งของ ebit การตั้งค่าเหมือนกัน จะไม่พูด
ส่วนนั้นซ้ำ และผลลัพธ์คือสถานะที่แสดงบนหน้าจอ ซึ่งก็คือบิตสุ่มร่วมกัน ดังนั้นสิ่งที่
channel นี้ทำก็คือแปลง ebit เป็นคู่บิตสุ่มคลาสสิกที่สัมพันธ์กันอย่างสมบูรณ์
และนั่นสอดคล้องกับการตีความที่กว้างกว่าของ channel นี้ การทำให้ค่านอกแนวทแยงของเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นเป็นศูนย์ เรากำลัง
โยนส่วนควอนตัมในเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นทิ้ง เหลือเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นแนวทแยงที่แทน
สถานะความน่าจะเป็นคลาสสิก อีกวิธีในการคิดเรื่องนี้คือ channel นี้แทน channel คลาสสิกที่สมบูรณ์แบบไม่มีสัญญาณรบกวนที่ส่งบิต
ถ้าเราใส่สถานะศูนย์หรือสถานะหนึ่ง หรือการรวมแบบนูนของสองสถานะนั้นเข้า channel สถานะนั้นออกมาไม่เปลี่ยน แต่ถ้าลอง
ใส่สถานะควอนตัมเข้าไป เช่น สถานะพลัส มันเหมือนกับว่า channel วัดสถานะนั้นด้วยการวัดฐานมาตรฐาน แล้ว
ส่งผลลัพธ์คลาสสิก ตัวอย่างสุดท้ายของ qubit channel คือ completely depolarizing channel สิ่งที่
channel นี้ทำคือให้เอาต์พุตเป็นสถานะผสมสมบูรณ์เสมอ มันคล้ายในบางแง่กับ qubit reset
channel ยกเว้นว่าเราได้สถานะผสมสมบูรณ์ที่มีประโยชน์น้อยกว่าออกมา แทนที่จะเป็น qubit ที่ถูกเริ่มต้นใหม่ วิธีที่เป็นธรรมชาติในการ
คิดเกี่ยวกับ channel นี้คือมันแทนสัญญาณรบกวนแบบสุดขีด และสำหรับ qubit channel แล้ว
มันรบกวนหนักสุดแล้วจริงๆ ผมไม่มีตัวช่วยจำดีๆ สำหรับจำว่าอันนี้ทำอะไร นอกจากจะบอกว่าโอเมก้าเป็นตัวอักษร
สุดท้ายของตัวอักษรกรีก และบางทีมันเกี่ยวข้องกับจุดจบของทุกสิ่ง และบางทีนี่คือสิ่งที่เกิดขึ้น
กับ qubit ทุกตัวในที่สุด ในแง่สัญญาณรบกวน มันสุดขีดจริงๆ แต่สิ่งหนึ่งที่เราทำได้คือพิจารณาการรวมแบบนูน
ของ channel นี้กับ identity channel อาจมีความน่าจะเป็นเล็กๆ เอปไซลอนสำหรับ
depolarization สมบูรณ์ นี่เป็นสัญญาณรบกวนแบบที่ไม่สุดขีดนัก ที่สถานะ qubit จะถูกปล่อยไว้เป็นส่วนใหญ่ แต่มี
โอกาสเล็กน้อยที่จะกลายเป็นสถานะผสมสมบูรณ์ ในเชิงเรขาคณิต เราคิดเรื่องนี้เป็นการหดตัวเล็กน้อยของ Bloch sphere เข้าหาจุดศูนย์กลาง
แล้วก็ เราทำอะไรคล้ายๆ กันได้กับ completely dephasing channel เพื่อจำลองกระบวนการ decoherence เช่น ที่สิ่งต่างๆ
กลายเป็นคลาสสิกมากขึ้นเล็กน้อยผ่านกระบวนการบางอย่าง นั่นก็คือสามตัวอย่างพื้นฐานของ qubit channel และเราจะ
กลับมาหามัน ส่วนใหญ่เป็นแหล่งตัวอย่างตลอดส่วนที่เหลือของบทเรียน ต่อไปเราจะพูดถึง representation
ทางคณิตศาสตร์ของ channel เริ่มจากคำถามพื้นฐาน การแปลงเชิงเส้นจากเวกเตอร์ไปเวกเตอร์สามารถ
แทนด้วยเมทริกซ์ได้เสมอในวิธีที่คุ้นเคย นั่นคือผลกระทบของการแปลงเชิงเส้นอธิบายโดยการคูณ
เมทริกซ์กับเวกเตอร์ แต่ channel เป็นการแปลงเชิงเส้นจากเมทริกซ์ไปเมทริกซ์ ไม่ใช่เวกเตอร์ไปเวกเตอร์ ดังนั้น
โดยทั่วไปเราจะแสดง channel ในแง่คณิตศาสตร์ได้ยังไง บางที channel พิเศษจะมีสูตรง่ายๆ
ที่อธิบายมัน และนั่นเป็นกรณีของตัวอย่าง qubit channel ที่เราพูดไปแล้ว แต่มัน
ไม่เหมาะกับกรณีทั่วไป เพราะจะไม่มีสูตรดีๆ แบบนั้นเสมอไป เพื่อเปรียบเทียบ ในสูตร
แบบย่อของข้อมูลควอนตัม เราใช้เมทริกซ์ unitary แทนการดำเนินการบนเวกเตอร์สถานะควอนตัม
เมทริกซ์ unitary ทุกตัวแทนการดำเนินการที่ถูกต้อง และการดำเนินการที่ถูกต้องทุกอันแสดงเป็นเมทริกซ์ unitary ได้ ดังนั้น
โดยพื้นฐานแล้ว คำถามนี้ถามว่าเราจะทำแบบนี้กับ channel ยังไง และคำตอบคือจริงๆ แล้วมีหลายวิธีในการแทน
channel ในแง่คณิตศาสตร์ โดยเฉพาะเราจะพูดถึงสามวิธีในการแทน channel ที่
ตั้งชื่อตามสามคนที่งานของพวกเขามีส่วนสำคัญในการพัฒนา Stinespring, Kraus และ Choi
ก่อนอื่นเราจะเห็นว่า representation ต่างๆ เหล่านี้ทำงานยังไง แล้วในส่วนสุดท้ายของบทเรียน เราจะเห็นว่า representation ทั้งสามเกี่ยวข้องกันยังไง และ
โดยเฉพาะวิธีแปลงระหว่างกัน เราจะเห็นด้วยว่า representation เหล่านี้จับข้อกำหนดที่เรามีสำหรับ channel ได้พอดี
นั่นคือเป็นการแปลงเชิงเส้นและแปลงเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นเป็นเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นเสมอ แม้เมื่อ
ถูกใช้กับแค่บางส่วนของระบบประกอบ อันแรกคือ Stinespring representation Willam Forrest Stine-
spring เป็นนักคณิตศาสตร์ที่ไม่ได้ทำงานเรื่องข้อมูลควอนตัม และ Stinespring representation ตามที่ผมจะอธิบาย
ในแง่หนึ่งเป็นอนุพันธ์ของงานของเขาเกี่ยวกับทฤษฎีตัวดำเนินการในทศวรรษ 1950 แต่งานนี้
เป็นส่วนสำคัญในการพัฒนาคณิตศาสตร์ที่ channel ควอนตัมตั้งอยู่ ไอเดียเบื้องหลังวิธีการแทน channel นี้คือทุก
channel สามารถนำไปใช้ได้ในลักษณะที่ผมจะอธิบาย ก่อนอื่นเราสร้างระบบประกอบที่ประกอบด้วย
อินพุตของ channel ที่เรากำลังนำไปใช้ รวมกับระบบทำงานที่เริ่มต้นแล้ว จากนั้น
การดำเนินการ unitary จะถูกทำบนระบบประกอบ และสุดท้าย ส่วนของระบบประกอบที่ได้
ที่ตรงกับเอาต์พุตของ channel จะถูกปล่อยไว้หรือส่งออก และส่วนที่เหลือจะถูกทิ้งหรือเทรซออก มันช่วยได้ที่จะ
แสดงในรูปของไดอะแกรม และง่ายที่สุดที่จะเริ่มจากกรณีพิเศษที่ระบบอินพุตและ
ระบบเอาต์พุตเหมือนกัน ไดอะแกรมนี้เหมือนกับไดอะแกรม circuit ควอนตัมเลย ยกเว้นว่าสาย
แทนระบบทั่วไปและไม่จำเป็นต้องเป็น qubit เดี่ยว เราเริ่มจากระบบอินพุต X ที่อยู่ในสถานะ
โร เราแนะนำระบบทำงาน W ที่เริ่มต้นแล้ว และในไดอะแกรมนี้ผมสมมติว่า 0 เป็นสถานะ
คลาสสิกของ W และเราให้ เค0 เป็นสถานะเริ่มต้นของระบบ แต่เราอาจกำหนดสถานะบริสุทธิ์ใดก็ได้
ของ W แล้วมองว่านั่นเป็นสถานะเริ่มต้น จากนั้นเราทำการดำเนินการ unitary บนคู่ WX แล้ว
เทรซระบบทำงานออก แล้วส่งออก X ตรงนี้ในไดอะแกรมผมใช้สัญลักษณ์กราวด์จาก
วิศวกรรมไฟฟ้าเพื่อบอกว่า W ถูกทิ้ง นั่นไม่จำเป็นต้องเป็นธรรมเนียมทั่วไป และคุณจะไม่
เจอสัญลักษณ์นั้นใน Qiskit ใน Qiskit คุณแค่เพิกเฉย qubit ที่คุณไม่สนใจ ประเด็นคือผมแค่อยากมีสัญลักษณ์ที่บอก
ชัดว่าเรากำลังทิ้งระบบ สำหรับจุดประสงค์ของการอภิปรายนี้ โดยทั่วไปเราไม่จำเป็นต้องให้
ระบบอินพุตและเอาต์พุตเหมือนกัน ดังนั้นเราอาจมีระบบเอาต์พุต Y พร้อมกับระบบ
ขยะ G ที่ถูกเทรซออก เพื่อให้ U เป็น unitary มันต้องเป็นเมทริกซ์จัตุรัส ดังนั้นมีข้อสมมติ
ว่าคู่ GY รวมกันมีจำนวนสถานะคลาสสิกเท่ากับคู่ WX เช่น อาจเป็นระบบที่
ประกอบด้วย qubit และระบบอินพุต X มี 5 qubit และ W มี 10 qubit ดังนั้น U เป็นการดำเนินการ
unitary บน 15 qubit อาจเป็นว่า Y มีแค่ 4 qubit ซึ่งหมายความว่า G มี 11 qubit
หรืออาจไม่ใช่ qubit เลย สิ่งสำคัญคือ WX รวมกันและ GY รวมกันมีจำนวน
สถานะคลาสสิกเท่ากัน เพื่อให้ U เป็น unitary ได้ การอธิบาย channel แบบนี้เรียกว่า Stinespring representation ของ channel ทีนี้มัน
ค่อนข้างตรงไปตรงมาที่จะโต้แย้งว่าการแปลงใดก็ตาม ฟี ที่อธิบายในลักษณะนี้เป็น channel ที่ถูกต้อง
โดยเฉพาะถ้าเราเริ่มจากเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นแล้วเพิ่มระบบทำงานเข้าไป เราจะ
ได้เมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นแน่นอน เราสังเกตไปแล้วว่าการใช้การดำเนินการ unitary ให้ channel ที่ถูกต้อง และ
ถ้าเรามีเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นของระบบประกอบแล้วเทรซระบบหนึ่งออก เราก็จะได้เมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่น ดังนั้นเมื่อเราประกอบ
ขั้นตอนเหล่านี้เข้าด้วยกัน เรารับประกันได้ว่ามันแปลงเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นเป็นเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นเสมอ และมันก็เป็นเชิงเส้นด้วย
สิ่งที่ไม่ชัดเจนเลยตอนนี้คือว่าทุก channel สามารถนำไปใช้ในลักษณะนี้ได้จริง สำหรับการเลือก
ระบบทำงานและระบบขยะ รวมถึงการดำเนินการ unitary U บางอย่าง แน่นอน แต่นั่นเป็นจริง และเราจะ
เห็นว่าทำไมตอนจบบทเรียน นี่คือตัวอย่างของ Stinespring representation สำหรับ completely de-
phasing qubit channel และเพื่อความชัดเจน ตอนนี้สายเป็น qubit และนี่คือ controlled-
NOT ธรรมดา มันง่ายมาก qubit อินพุตอยู่ด้านบน และเราแนะนำ qubit ทำงานที่เริ่มต้นเป็นสถานะ
ศูนย์ จากนั้นเราทำการดำเนินการ controlled-NOT โดย qubit อินพุตเป็นตัวควบคุมและ qubit ทำงานเป็น
เป้าหมาย จากนั้น qubit ทำงานถูกเทรซออก โดยสัญชาตญาณแล้ว มันสมเหตุสมผล
ที่นี่จะเป็นการนำ completely dephasing channel ไปใช้ เพราะ controlled-NOT ทำตัวเหมือนการวัดฐานมาตรฐานบน qubit
บน โดยคัดลอกสถานะคลาสสิกลงไปที่ qubit ล่าง จากนั้นผลลัพธ์ก็ถูก
โยนทิ้ง แต่เราก็สามารถคำนวณดูได้ และแน่นอนว่าเป็นความคิดที่ดีที่จะทำ เพราะเราจริงๆ
ไม่ควรเชื่อสัญชาตญาณมากเกินไป เราเริ่มจากเขียนเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่น representation ของ
qubit สองตัวหลังจากแนะนำ qubit ทำงาน และสังเกตว่าเราใช้ธรรมเนียมลำดับ qubit ตามปกติ
ที่ qubit ล่างเป็นตัวซ้ายและ qubit บนอยู่ทางขวา เราสามารถแสดงเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นนี้
อย่างชัดเจนเป็นเมทริกซ์ 4x4 จริงๆ ตามที่แสดงบนหน้าจอ จากนั้นเราคำนวณผลกระทบ
ที่ controlled-NOT gate มีต่อเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นนี้ เราจึง conjugate ด้วยเมทริกซ์ unitary ที่เกี่ยวข้องกับ
gate นี้ โดยจำธรรมเนียมลำดับ qubit ไว้ด้วย ดังนั้นนี่คือเมทริกซ์ unitary ที่ถูกต้อง
และผลลัพธ์แสดงตรงนี้ จริงๆ แล้ว controlled-NOT gate
สลับตำแหน่งค่าของเมทริกซ์เดิมเราไปเล็กน้อย ดังนั้นตอนนี้ค่าที่อาจไม่เป็นศูนย์อยู่ที่
สี่มุม เหลือแค่คำนวณ partial trace และเราทำได้โดยตรงจากเมทริกซ์ แต่อีก
ทางเลือกคือแปลงเป็นสัญกรณ์ Dirac ตามที่แสดงบนหน้าจอ แล้วจะค่อนข้างง่ายที่จะประเมิน
ว่าเกิดอะไรขึ้นเมื่อเราเทรซ qubit ทางซ้ายออกภายในแต่ละพจน์ และผลลัพธ์คือแค่
พจน์ที่ตรงกับค่าแนวทแยงของโรที่รอดมา เราจึง dephase qubit ได้ตามที่
คาดไว้ เช่นเคย ลองตรวจสอบด้วยตัวเอง ค่อยๆ ทำตามจังหวะของคุณ ถ้าเลือกที่จะทำ มันเป็น
ตัวอย่างที่ดีสำหรับฝึกทำงานกับเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นและ partial
trace นั่นไม่ใช่วิธีเดียวที่จะนำ completely dephasing channel ไปใช้ นี่คือ Stinespring representation ทางเลือกสำหรับ
channel นี้ ผมจะไม่ลงรายละเอียดการคำนวณในวิดีโอนี้ แต่จะแสดงให้เห็นสั้นๆ ในกรณีที่อยากหยุดวิดีโอแล้ว
ดูใกล้ๆ วิธีที่มันทำงานคล้ายกับอันแรก แต่รายละเอียด
ต่างกัน คราวนี้เราเริ่มด้วย Hadamard gate บน qubit ทำงานซึ่งทำให้มันเป็นสถานะพลัส และถ้า
เรากระจายเทนเซอร์โปรดักต์ออก เราจะได้เมทริกซ์ที่แสดงบนหน้าจอ เพื่อใช้ controlled-Z gate เรา
conjugate ด้วยเมทริกซ์ unitary ที่เกี่ยวข้อง และผลของการทำแบบนั้นคือใส่เครื่องหมายลบเข้าไปใน
เมทริกซ์ โดยเฉพาะแถวสุดท้ายและคอลัมน์สุดท้ายถูกคูณด้วยลบ 1
และคราวนี้จะค่อนข้างยุ่งถ้าแปลงเป็นสัญกรณ์ Dirac เราจึงคำนวณ partial trace
โดยตรง เมื่อเราเทรซ qubit แรกจากสองตัวออก สิ่งที่เราได้คือผลรวมของบล็อกแนวทแยง 2x2 สองบล็อก
ผลลัพธ์สุดท้ายก็คือเราได้ dephase qubit อีกครั้ง นั่นเร็วมาก และถ้ายัง
ไม่คุ้นเคยกับการคำนวณแบบนี้ ก็ค่อยๆ ทำ ความเร็วไม่สำคัญ
ตรงนี้ เพื่อปิดตัวอย่างนี้ ขอพูดถึงว่ามีไอเดียค่อนข้างง่ายเบื้องหลังการนำไปใช้นี้ ซึ่ง
แสดงออกได้ดีมากจากขั้นตอนสุดท้ายของการคำนวณที่เราเพิ่งดูผ่าน วิธีพูดที่กระชับกว่าคือ
ถ้าเราเฉลี่ยเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่น qubit ที่กำหนดกับเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นนั้นที่ถูก conjugate ด้วยเมทริกซ์ Pauli Z
นั่นก็เหมือนกับการ dephase ดังนั้น completely dephasing channel บังเอิญเป็น mixed unitary
channel ที่เราไม่ทำอะไร หรือพูดอีกอย่างคือทำ identity operation หรือเราทำ Z gate แต่ละอย่าง
ด้วยความน่าจะเป็น 1/2 ดีที่รู้ สรุปแล้ว เรามีสอง
Stinespring representation ต่างกันของ completely dephasing channel และนั่นบอกเราอะไรสำคัญ นั่นคือ Stinespring representation
ไม่ซ้ำกัน และจริงๆ แล้วมีจำนวนอนันต์สำหรับ channel ใดก็ได้ ต่อไปเราจะพูดถึง Kraus
representation ของ channel ซึ่งให้เราวิธีที่สะดวกในการแสดง channel ผ่านการคูณ
เมทริกซ์และการบวก Kraus representation ตั้งชื่อตาม Karl Kraus ซึ่งเป็นนักฟิสิกส์ที่
ทำงานรายละเอียดคณิตศาสตร์พื้นฐานของ channel และสูตรทั่วไปของข้อมูลควอนตัมในวงกว้าง โดยทั่วไป
Kraus representation คือนิพจน์ของ channel ในรูปแบบที่แสดงบนหน้าจอ โดยเฉพาะเรามี
ชุดของเมทริกซ์ซึ่งตรงนี้ตั้งชื่อว่า A0 ถึง A N ลบ 1 สำหรับจำนวนเต็มบวก N และมันกำหนด
ผลกระทบของ channel บนอินพุต โร ใดก็ได้ตามสูตร สรุปคือเรา conjugate โร ด้วยแต่ละเมทริกซ์เหล่านี้
ซึ่งมักเรียกว่าเมทริกซ์ Kraus ในบริบทนี้ จากนั้นรวมผลลัพธ์ขึ้นมา และนั่นให้เอาต์พุต เมทริกซ์ทั้งหมดต้องมี
มิติเดียวกัน และเฉพาะเจาะจงคือ คอลัมน์ต้องตรงกับสถานะคลาสสิกของระบบอินพุต และ
แถวต้องตรงกับสถานะคลาสสิกของระบบเอาต์พุต ถ้าเป็นแบบนั้น เมื่อเราหาผลคูณ AK คูณ โร คูณ AK แด็กเกอร์ สำหรับ
K ใดก็ได้ เราจะได้เมทริกซ์จัตุรัสที่แถวและคอลัมน์ตรงกับสถานะคลาสสิกของระบบเอาต์พุต
และมันสมเหตุสมผลที่นิพจน์จะให้เมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นของระบบเอาต์พุต ทีนี้ ไม่ใช่ว่า
สำหรับการเลือกเมทริกซ์ Kraus เหล่านี้ตามอำเภอใจจะได้ channel ที่ถูกต้อง อย่างไรก็ตาม มีเงื่อนไขที่ค่อนข้างง่าย
บนเมทริกซ์ที่รับประกันว่าเราจะได้ channel ที่ถูกต้อง และเงื่อนไขนั้นคือสูตรที่แสดงตรงนี้
เฉพาะเจาะจงคือ ถ้าเรารวมผลคูณ AK แด็กเกอร์ คูณ AK ทุกค่าของ K
เราต้องได้เมทริกซ์เอกลักษณ์ และนั่นจะเป็นเมทริกซ์เอกลักษณ์ที่แถวและคอลัมน์ตรงกับ
สถานะคลาสสิกของระบบอินพุต เงื่อนไขนั้นต้องเป็นไปตามเพื่อให้การแปลงที่กำหนดโดย
สมการแรกเป็น channel ที่ถูกต้อง และปรากฏว่าทุก channel จริงๆ แล้วมี representation ในรูปแบบ
นี้ ตราบใดที่เราให้ N ใหญ่พอ นี่คือตัวอย่างบางส่วนของ Kraus
representation เริ่มจาก qubit reset channel เราหา Kraus representation สำหรับ channel นี้ได้โดยใช้
เมทริกซ์ Kraus สองตัว เค0 บรา 0 และ เค0 บรา 1 ดังนั้น N เท่ากับสองในตัวอย่างนี้
เราแทนค่าเหล่านี้ลงในสูตรทั่วไป เรามีแค่สองพจน์จึงง่ายที่จะเขียนผลรวม
และถ้าเราทำให้ง่ายขึ้นและจำได้ว่านิพจน์ในวงเล็บคือเทรซของโร เราจะเห็นว่าได้
qubit reset channel เรายังตรวจสอบได้ว่าเงื่อนไขที่ต้องการบนเมทริกซ์เหล่านี้เป็นไปตาม แค่แทนค่าเมทริกซ์ Kraus
ลงในสมการแล้วประเมิน เราจะได้เมทริกซ์เอกลักษณ์ตามที่ต้องการ สำหรับอีกตัวอย่าง มาดู
completely dephasing channel อีกครั้ง ใช้เมทริกซ์ เค0 บรา 0 และ เค1 บรา 1 ได้ผล และตรวจสอบได้โดย
กระจายผลรวมออกแล้วเห็นค่อนข้างชัดว่าเราได้สิ่งที่ต้องการ และเงื่อนไขที่ต้องการก็เป็นไปตามอีกด้วย อีก
ทางเลือกคือให้ A0 เป็นเมทริกซ์เอกลักษณ์หารด้วยรากที่สองของ 2 และ A1 เป็น
ซิกม่า Z หารด้วยรากที่สองของ 2 และถ้าเราประเมิน เราจะเห็นว่าได้ completely dephasing channel อีกครั้ง จากการสังเกต
ที่เราทำเกี่ยวกับ channel นี้ก่อนหน้าในบทเรียน และอีกครั้งเงื่อนไขที่ต้องการก็ค่อนข้างตรงไปตรงมาที่จะ
ตรวจสอบ เป็นแบบฝึกหัดที่จะลองทำ ถ้ารู้สึกว่ามีประโยชน์ ลองพิจารณา completely depolarizing
channel ซึ่งให้เอาต์พุตเป็นสถานะผสมสมบูรณ์สำหรับเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นทุกตัวที่ใส่เข้าไป สำหรับอันนี้ต้องใช้เมทริกซ์ Kraus สี่ตัว
ไม่สามารถหา Kraus representation ที่ N เท่ากับสามหรือน้อยกว่าได้ นี่คือตัวเลือกหนึ่งที่ได้ผล และ
นี่อีกตัวเลือก แบบฝึกหัดคือตรวจสอบว่าตัวเลือกเหล่านี้ได้ผล รวมถึงตรวจสอบว่าเงื่อนไขที่ต้องการ
เป็นไปตาม ควรชี้ว่าทางเลือกที่สองพื้นฐานแล้วบอกว่าเป็นไปได้ที่จะ depolarize qubit อย่างสมบูรณ์ หรือพูดอีกอย่างคือ
สุ่มมันให้หมด โดยสุ่มเลือกหนึ่งในสี่เมทริกซ์ Pauli รวมถึงเมทริกซ์เอกลักษณ์ แล้วใช้
การดำเนินการ unitary ที่ตรงกันกับ qubit ดังนั้น completely depolarizing channel เป็นอีกตัวอย่างของ mixed
unitary channel representation ของ channel ตัวสุดท้ายจากสามแบบที่เราจะพูดถึงคือ Choi representation Man-Duen Choi
เป็นนักคณิตศาสตร์ที่ทำงานเรื่องทฤษฎีเมทริกซ์และหัวข้ออื่นๆ และ Choi representation ตั้งชื่อเพื่อเป็นเกียรติแก่เขา
จากบทความที่สวยงามมากที่เขาตีพิมพ์ในปี 1975 ที่ในแง่หนึ่งผูกทุกอย่างเข้าด้วยกัน Choi
representation ของ channel ฟี เป็นเมทริกซ์ตัวเดียว ที่โดยทั่วไปแทนด้วย J ฟี และเฉพาะเจาะจง ถ้า
ระบบอินพุตมี N สถานะคลาสสิก และระบบเอาต์พุตมี M สถานะคลาสสิก Choi representation ของ ฟี จะเป็น
เมทริกซ์จัตุรัส N คูณ M ต่อ N คูณ M ก่อนจะบอกว่าเมทริกซ์ถูกกำหนดยังไงเป๊ะๆ ขอพูดถึงสมบัติสำคัญ
สองสามอย่างของมัน ซึ่งให้แรงจูงใจสำหรับ representation ในแบบที่นิยามจริงๆ อาจไม่ทำ อย่างน้อยใน
เบื้องต้น อันแรก ต่างจากทั้ง Stinespring representation และ Kraus representation ตรงที่ Choi representation
เป็นสิ่งที่เรียกว่า faithful representation หมายความว่าทุก channel มีแค่ตัวเดียว และนั่นสำคัญมาก
เพราะมันบอกว่าสอง channel เหมือนกันก็ต่อเมื่อ Choi representation ของมันเหมือนกัน ดังนั้นถ้า
มีคำอธิบาย channel สองแบบ เช่น Stinespring representation สองแบบ หรือ Kraus representation สองแบบ หรืออาจอย่างละ
อัน แล้วอยากรู้ว่าจริงๆ แล้วเป็น channel เดียวกันหรือเปล่า แค่คำนวณ Choi representation แล้ว
ตรวจว่าเท่ากันหรือไม่ สมบัติที่สองคือมีเงื่อนไขที่ตรวจสอบง่ายบน Choi representation ที่เป็นจริงก็ต่อเมื่อ
เรามี channel ที่ถูกต้อง สมบัตินั้นไม่ได้พิเศษขนาดนั้น เราพูดแบบเดียวกันได้กับอีกสอง representation แต่เป็นสมบัติที่ดี
ที่มีอยู่ดี และเราจะพูดถึงมันในรายละเอียดเพิ่มเติมในภายหลัง อีกสิ่งที่ควรรู้เกี่ยวกับ Choi representation คือถึงแม้เรา
แทน channel ด้วยเมทริกซ์ เมทริกซ์นี้ไม่ได้แทน channel โดยตรงในฐานะการแปลงเชิงเส้น จริงๆ แล้ว
เป็นธรรมชาติกว่าที่จะเชื่อมโยง Choi representation กับเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นที่แทนสถานะบางอย่าง
มากกว่าจะคิดว่า Choi representation อธิบายการแปลงเชิงเส้น อย่างไรก็ตาม เป็นไปได้ที่จะกู้คืนผลกระทบของ channel จาก
Choi representation ของมันโดยใช้สูตรค่อนข้างง่าย แต่ไม่ง่ายเท่าการคูณเมทริกซ์ธรรมดา
พอเป็นบทนำแล้ว มาดูนิยามจริงกัน สมมติว่าเรามี channel ฟี จากระบบ X ไปยังระบบ Y
และสมมติว่าเซตสถานะคลาสสิกของระบบอินพุต X คือซิกม่า เราไม่จำเป็นต้องอ้างอิงเซตสถานะคลาสสิกของระบบเอาต์พุต ดังนั้น
สำหรับนิยามไม่จำเป็นต้องตั้งชื่อ Choi representation ของ ฟี กำหนดโดยนิพจน์
ที่แสดงบนหน้าจอ เรามีผลรวมที่ครอบคลุมสถานะคลาสสิก A และ B ทั้งหมดสำหรับระบบอินพุต และเรา
รวม เค A บรา B เทนเซอร์กับ channel ฟี ที่ใช้กับ เค A บรา B ดังนั้น
representation นี้กำหนดโดยสูตร และมีสองสามวิธีที่เราคิดเกี่ยวกับสูตรนี้ได้ ก่อนจะพูดถึง ขอ
บอกว่าบางที Choi representation ถูกกำหนดในวิธีที่ต่างกันเล็กน้อย ที่ลำดับของสอง tensor factor สลับกัน หมายความ
ว่า ฟี ของ เค A บรา ปรากฏเป็น tensor factor แรกแทนที่จะเป็นตัวที่สอง แต่สองวิธีนี้
เท่ากันภายใต้ความสมมาตรง่ายๆ นี้ แต่หมายความว่าเมื่อใช้ representation นี้ ควร
ชี้แจงว่าใช้ลำดับไหน ลำดับนี้เป็นแบบที่ทำใน Qiskit และยังดีกว่าสำหรับ
อธิบาย representation ในเชิงภาพด้วยเมทริกซ์บล็อก นี่จึงเป็นแบบที่เราจะใช้ เพื่อให้แม่นยำขึ้นเกี่ยวกับคำอธิบายเมทริกซ์บล็อก
ถ้าเราสมมติว่าเซตสถานะคลาสสิกซิกม่าประกอบด้วยจำนวนเต็มจาก 0 ถึง N ลบ 1
สำหรับจำนวนเต็มบวก N เราสามารถเขียน J ฟี เป็นเมทริกซ์บล็อกอีกแบบตามที่แสดงตรงนี้บน
หน้าจอ พูดอีกอย่าง Choi representation ของ ฟี คือเมทริกซ์ที่เราได้จากการประเมิน ฟี บนแต่ละ
เมทริกซ์อินพุตที่มีค่าหนึ่งเท่ากับ 1 พอดี โดยค่าอื่นเป็นศูนย์ทั้งหมด แล้วจัดเรียง
เป็นเมทริกซ์อย่างเป็นธรรมชาติ อาจไม่ชัดตั้งแต่แรกว่าทำไมเราถึงอยากสร้างเมทริกซ์แบบนี้ แต่
มันมีประโยชน์จริงๆ สิ่งหนึ่งที่ต้องสังเกตคือเซตที่ประกอบด้วยเมทริกซ์ เค A บรา B เมื่อ
A และ B ครอบคลุมจำนวนเต็มจาก 0 ถึง N ลบ 1 สร้างเป็นฐานของปริภูมิเมทริกซ์ N คูณ N ทั้งหมด ดังนั้นถ้า
มีเมทริกซ์นี้ เราก็กำหนดได้แน่นอนว่า ฟี ทำอะไรกับเมทริกซ์ N คูณ N ใดก็ได้โดยความเป็นเชิงเส้น
เฉพาะเจาะจงคือโดยการหาการรวมเชิงเส้นที่เหมาะสมของบล็อก ดังนั้นเมทริกซ์ J ฟี กำหนด
ฟี เป็นการแปลงเชิงเส้นได้อย่างเดียว อีกวิธีในการคิดเกี่ยวกับ Choi representation ของ channel คือ
มันแทนสถานะเป็นเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่น เมื่อถูกนอร์มัลไลซ์ เฉพาะเจาะจงคือหารด้วยจำนวน
สถานะคลาสสิกของระบบอินพุต ซึ่งผมจะยังใช้ N ตัวเล็กแทน นี่จะให้
เมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นเสมอ ซึ่งมักเรียกว่า Choi state ของ channel นี่คือวิธีทำงานในรายละเอียดเพิ่มเติม
จินตนาการก่อนว่าเรามีสองสำเนาเหมือนกันของระบบอินพุต และเราพิจารณาเวกเตอร์สถานะควอนตัม S
ที่แสดงบนหน้าจอ ซึ่งแทนสถานะที่เรียกว่าสถานะพันกันสูงสุดของคู่ระบบเหมือนกันนี้ เช่น
ถ้าซิกม่าเป็นตัวอักษรแบบไบนารี นี่จะเป็นสถานะ ฟี+ แต่เราคิดถึงสถานะที่กำหนดแบบเดียวกันสำหรับ
ซิกม่าใดก็ได้ และสิ่งที่เราได้คือสถานะที่พันกันมาก และจริงๆ แล้วพันกันมากที่สุดเท่าที่จะเป็นไปได้
สำหรับการเลือกระบบเหล่านี้ เพื่อให้ได้เมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่น representation ของสถานะ เราคูณเวกเตอร์สถานะกับ conjugate transpose ตามปกติ และ
มันมีหน้าตาแบบนี้ และสุดท้ายถ้าเราคิดเกี่ยวกับ Choi representation ของ channel หารด้วย N เราจะเห็นว่ามันคือสถานะที่
เราจะได้ถ้าใช้ channel ฟี กับระบบที่สอง ในรูปของภาพ นี่คือ
หน้าตาของมัน เรามีสองสำเนาของระบบ X ในสถานะพันกันสูงสุด S channel ฟี ถูก
ใช้กับระบบที่สองซึ่งอยู่ด้านบนในไดอะแกรม และสถานะที่ได้คือ Choi state ของ ฟี แน่นอนเราปกติจะไม่
ตั้งชื่อเดียวกันให้กับสองระบบต่างกันแบบนี้ โดยทั่วไปไม่มีประโยชน์ที่จะตั้งชื่อเดียวกันให้สองสิ่งต่างกัน แต่มันสมเหตุสมผล
ในกรณีนี้แค่เพื่อสร้างความเชื่อมโยงกับ Choi representation มีผลที่ตามมาสองสามอย่างที่เราสรุปได้ทันทีจากวิธีมอง
Choi representation แบบนี้ อันแรกคือ เพราะ Choi state เป็นเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่น สมมติว่า ฟี เป็น
channel ที่ถูกต้อง เราสรุปได้ว่า Choi representation ของ ฟี ต้องเป็นกึ่งบวกแน่นอน จำไว้ว่า
ข้อกำหนดที่เราวางไว้สำหรับ channel คือต้องแปลงเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นเป็นเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นเสมอ และนี่
เป็นแค่กรณีพิเศษหนึ่งของสิ่งนี้ ผลที่ตามมาอันที่สองคือ ถ้าเราเอา Choi state สำหรับ channel ฟี ใดก็ได้
แล้วทิ้งระบบเอาต์พุต Y เราต้องเหลือสถานะผสมสมบูรณ์บนระบบอินพุต X นั่น
เป็นเพราะการใช้ channel กับระบบแล้วโยนระบบที่ได้ลงถังขยะ เท่ากับแค่โยนระบบเดิมลง
ถังขยะ และถ้าเราทำแบบนั้นกับสถานะพันกันสูงสุดของเรา เมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นที่เราจะเหลือคือ
เมทริกซ์เอกลักษณ์หารด้วย N หรือพูดอีกอย่างคือสถานะผสมสมบูรณ์สำหรับระบบ X ไอเดียในแง่
คณิตศาสตร์มากขึ้นคือ การประกอบ channel ใดก็ได้กับเทรซบนระบบเอาต์พุตต้องเท่ากับเทรซบน
ระบบอินพุต และนั่นเป็นเพราะ channel ต้องรักษาเทรซ โดยอาศัยข้อเท็จจริงที่ว่ามันเป็นการแปลงเชิงเส้นที่
แปลงเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นเป็นเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นเสมอ เมื่อเรามีสมการนี้ เราสามารถเคลียร์ตัวหาร N
จากทั้งสองข้างเพื่อให้ได้เงื่อนไขที่สะอาดกว่า พูดง่ายๆ คือการทำ partial trace บนระบบเอาต์พุต
ของ Choi representation ของ channel ต้องให้เมทริกซ์เอกลักษณ์บนระบบอินพุต สรุปแล้ว Choi
representation ของ channel เป็นกึ่งบวกแน่นอนเสมอ และถ้าเราเทรซระบบเอาต์พุตออก เราจำเป็นต้อง
เหลือเมทริกซ์เอกลักษณ์บนระบบอินพุต ปรากฏว่าเหล่านี้ไม่ใช่แค่เงื่อนไขจำเป็น แต่
เป็นเงื่อนไขเพียงพอด้วย หมายความว่าถ้า ฟี เป็นการแปลงเชิงเส้นใดก็ได้ และเงื่อนไขสองข้อนี้บังเอิญ
เป็นจริง ฟี ก็ต้องเป็น channel ที่ถูกต้อง และเราจะเห็นว่าทำไมตอนจบบทเรียน
มาดูตัวอย่างกัน เริ่มจาก completely dephasing channel เพื่อคำนวณ Choi representation แค่ประเมิน
ตามสูตร completely dephasing channel ปล่อย เค A บรา B ไว้เมื่อ A เท่ากับ B และนอกจากนั้นเอาต์พุต
เป็นศูนย์ ดังนั้นพจน์ในผลรวมที่รอดคือตัวที่ A เท่ากับ B และผลลัพธ์แสดงบน
หน้าจอด้วยสัญกรณ์ Dirac เรายังมองเป็นเมทริกซ์บล็อกได้ เดลต้าปล่อยค่าแนวทแยงไว้และทำให้ค่า
นอกแนวทแยงเป็นศูนย์ เราจึงเหลือเมทริกซ์ที่มีค่า 1 ที่มุมซ้ายบนและมุมขวาล่าง โดยค่าอื่น
เป็นศูนย์ทั้งหมด และนั่นสอดคล้องกับนิพจน์แรก สำหรับอีกตัวอย่าง มาพิจารณา completely depolarizing channel อีกครั้ง เรา
เริ่มจากเขียนสูตร และเหมือนตัวอย่างก่อนหน้า เราไม่ได้ส่วนร่วมจากผลรวม
เมื่อ A ไม่เท่ากับ B และคราวนี้เมื่อ A เท่ากับ B เราได้สถานะผสมสมบูรณ์ และเราทำให้ง่ายได้เป็น
1/2 คูณเมทริกซ์เอกลักษณ์ 2x2 เทนเซอร์กับตัวมันเอง ซึ่งคือ 1/2 คูณเมทริกซ์เอกลักษณ์
4x4 เรายังคิดในรูปเมทริกซ์บล็อกได้ และแน่นอนเราได้ผลลัพธ์เดียวกัน และเป็น
ตัวอย่างสุดท้าย มาพิจารณา identity channel สำหรับ qubit ตัวเดียว เป็นอันง่าย นี่คือสูตร และ
แน่นอน identity channel ไม่ทำอะไรเลย และเราคิดถึงผลลัพธ์เป็นสองเท่าของเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นที่เกี่ยวกับสถานะ ฟี+ ได้ และนั่น
สอดคล้องกับสิ่งที่เราคาดจากการคิดเกี่ยวกับ Choi state ของ channel นี้ และนี่คือในรูปเมทริกซ์บล็อก สังเกตโดยเฉพาะว่า Choi
representation ของ identity channel ไม่ใช่เมทริกซ์เอกลักษณ์ มันเป็นเมทริกซ์นี้ ตอนนี้เราเห็นสามวิธีต่างกัน
ในการแทน channel ทางคณิตศาสตร์ นั่นคือ Stinespring representation, Kraus representation และ Choi
representation และเรายังมีนิยามของ channel คือ channel เป็นการแปลงเชิงเส้นที่
แปลงเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นเป็นเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นเสมอ แม้เมื่อ channel ถูกใช้กับแค่บางส่วนของระบบประกอบ คำถามที่เป็นธรรมชาติและสำคัญมาก
ที่ต้องถามตอนนี้คือ เรารู้ได้ยังไงว่าสิ่งเหล่านี้เท่ากันทั้งหมด เช่น เรารู้ได้ยังไงว่าทุก
การแปลงที่อธิบายโดย representation ใดก็ได้เป็น channel ที่ถูกต้องจริง และเรารู้ได้ยังไงว่าเราไม่ได้ตก channel ไหนไป
ส่วนที่เหลือของบทเรียนอธิบายว่าทั้งหมดนี้สามารถให้เหตุผลทางคณิตศาสตร์ได้ยังไง ถ้ายินดียอมรับความเท่ากันของสิ่งเหล่านี้แล้วไม่สนใจว่าให้เหตุผลยังไง
ก็สามารถข้ามส่วนที่เหลือของวิดีโอได้เลย แต่ผมคิดว่าข้อโต้แย้งนี้ค่อนข้าง
เฉียบ และเป็นตัวอย่างที่ดีของรูปแบบการพิสูจน์ทางคณิตศาสตร์แบบหนึ่งที่เจอเรื่อยๆ ในทฤษฎีข้อมูลควอนตัม ผมจะไม่
ลงรายละเอียดทั้งหมด บางส่วนจะปล่อยให้คุณ หรือคุณสามารถหาได้ในเนื้อหาที่เขียนของบทเรียนนี้ ที่ทุกอย่างเขียนไว้
อย่างละเอียด แต่ผมหวังว่าจะนำเสนอภาพที่ค่อนข้างชัดเจนว่าทั้งหมดทำงานยังไง สิ่งที่เราต้องการทำคือพิสูจน์
ความเท่ากันของชุดข้อความ และวิธีทำคือตั้งวงจรของการอนุมาน โดยเฉพาะเราจะเริ่ม
จากนิยามของ channel หมายถึงการแปลงเชิงเส้นที่แปลงเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นเป็นเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นเสมอ
จากนิยามนี้ เราสรุปได้ว่า Choi representation ของ channel นี้ต้องเป็นไปตามสองเงื่อนไขที่เรา
พูดถึงไปแล้ว และจริงๆ เราทำไปแล้ว นี่ถูกพูดถึงในบริบทของ Choi state ของ channel จากนั้นเราลืมเรื่อง
นิยามทั้งหมด แล้วทำงานจาก Choi representation และจากสองเงื่อนไขของ Choi representation เราสรุปว่าต้องมี
Kraus representation ของการแปลง ฟี จากนั้นทำแบบเดียวกัน เราลืมเรื่อง Choi representation แล้วทำงาน
จาก Kraus representation ใดก็ได้ และจากมันเราสรุปว่าต้องมี Stinespring representation สำหรับการแปลง ฟี แล้วก็
ข้อโต้แย้งเหล่านี้จะเป็นกลไกในแง่หนึ่ง ซึ่งทำให้เราแปลงระหว่าง representation ตามลูกศรสำหรับ channel เฉพาะได้ถ้าต้องการ
การอนุมานสุดท้ายคือให้เหตุผลว่าถ้าเรามี Stinespring representation สำหรับการแปลง ฟี
การแปลงนั้นต้องเป็น channel ที่ถูกต้อง และอีกครั้ง เราทำไปแล้วตรงนี้ คราวนี้ในบริบทของ Stinespring
representation รวมกันแล้ว การอนุมานทั้งสี่นี้เผยว่าสี่สิ่งนี้เท่ากันทั้งหมด เพราะเริ่มจากอันไหนก็ได้แล้ว
ตามการอนุมานไปเรื่อยๆ ก็ไปถึงอันอื่นได้ทั้งหมด เราจะเริ่มจากการอนุมานแรก
ซึ่งก็คือ ถ้าเรามี channel ฟี หมายถึงการแปลงเชิงเส้นที่แปลงเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นเป็นเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นเสมอ มันจะมี Choi
representation ที่เป็นไปตามสองเงื่อนไขที่เราระบุก่อนหน้า นั่นคือเป็นกึ่งบวกแน่นอน
และถ้าเราเทรซระบบเอาต์พุตออก เราจะได้เมทริกซ์เอกลักษณ์บนระบบอินพุต และอย่างที่พูดไป
เราครอบคลุมการอนุมานนี้แล้วในบริบทของ Choi state โดยเฉพาะเมื่อเราหาร Choi representation ของ channel ด้วย N จำนวน
สถานะคลาสสิกของระบบอินพุต เราจะได้เมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่น และยิ่งกว่านั้น สถานะลดรูปของระบบอินพุต
X สำหรับสถานะนั้นคือสถานะผสมสมบูรณ์ หรือพูดอีกอย่างคือเมทริกซ์เอกลักษณ์หารด้วย N การเคลียร์ตัวหารให้สองเงื่อนไข
ของเรา ดังนั้นการอนุมานนี้ค่อนข้างเร็วและง่าย เพราะเราครอบคลุมไปแล้ว
ทีนี้มาดูการอนุมานที่สอง คราวนี้เราเริ่มจาก Choi representation ของการแปลง ซึ่ง
เราสมมติว่าเป็นไปตามสองเงื่อนไข และเป้าหมายคือหา Kraus representation สำหรับการแปลงนี้ที่
เป็นไปตามเงื่อนไขที่เราพูดถึงก่อนหน้า การอนุมานนี้ค่อนข้างเป็นกลไกในแง่หนึ่ง เราต้องใช้
พีชคณิตเชิงเส้นนิดหน่อย และส่วนใหญ่จะเป็นการจัดการเมทริกซ์และเวกเตอร์อย่าง
ฉลาด มันเริ่มจากข้อสมมติว่า Choi representation เป็นกึ่งบวกแน่นอน ซึ่งเป็นเงื่อนไขแรกจากสองข้อที่เรา
สมมติ แนวคิดเมทริกซ์กึ่งบวกแน่นอนสำคัญขั้นพื้นฐานในข้อมูลควอนตัม และไม่ใช่แค่ในบริบทของเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่น
เท่านั้น มันสำคัญอย่างยิ่งตรงนี้ เราทำไม่ได้โดยไม่มีมัน โดยเฉพาะข้อสมมติ
ว่า J ฟี เป็นกึ่งบวกแน่นอนทำให้เราแสดงมันในรูปแบบบนหน้าจอได้ สำหรับเวกเตอร์
S0 ถึง S N ลบ 1 บางตัว และจำนวนเต็มบวก N บางค่า และขอพูดชัดๆ ว่าเวกเตอร์เหล่านี้
ไม่จำเป็นต้องเป็นเวกเตอร์หนึ่งหน่วย วิธีหนึ่งที่เราจะได้นิพจน์แบบนี้มาจากทฤษฎีบทสเปกตรัลสำหรับเมทริกซ์
กึ่งบวกแน่นอน ซึ่งพูดถึงในบทเรียนก่อนหน้า ตรงนี้เราไม่เห็นค่าลักษณะเฉพาะปรากฏชัดเจนเหมือนในการแยก
สเปกตรัล แต่จำว่าค่าลักษณะเฉพาะของเมทริกซ์กึ่งบวกแน่นอนเป็นจำนวนจริงไม่ลบเสมอ และจำไว้ด้วยว่าเรา
ไม่ได้กำหนดให้เวกเตอร์ S0 ถึง S N ลบ 1 เป็นเวกเตอร์หนึ่งหน่วย ดังนั้นสิ่งที่เราทำได้คือหารากที่สองของ
ค่าลักษณะเฉพาะแล้วคูณเข้ากับเวกเตอร์ลักษณะเฉพาะหนึ่งหน่วยที่เราได้จากการแยกสเปกตรัลเพื่อให้ได้
เวกเตอร์ S0 ถึง S N ลบ 1 จริงๆ แล้วไม่สำคัญสำหรับการพิสูจน์นี้ว่าเวกเตอร์เหล่านี้ตั้งฉากกัน เรา
ได้มาจากการแยกสเปกตรัล แต่เราจะไม่ใช้มัน และถ้าเรามีนิพจน์อื่นของ J ฟี แบบนี้ที่ไม่ได้มาจาก
ทฤษฎีบทสเปกตรัล มันก็ใช้ได้เหมือนกัน ตอนนี้เราแยกเวกเตอร์แต่ละตัวตามที่แสดงบนหน้าจอ และ
นี่เหมือนกับที่เราทำถ้าเวกเตอร์เหล่านี้เป็นเวกเตอร์สถานะควอนตัมของคู่ระบบ XY และเรา
ทำการวัดฐานมาตรฐานบนระบบ X เพื่อความชัดเจน เราไม่ได้วัดอะไรตรงนี้ เราแค่เขียนเวกเตอร์ในรูปแบบนี้ซึ่ง
ทำได้เสมอ และตอนนี้มาถึงเคล็ดลับ เรากำหนดเมทริกซ์ Kraus A0 ถึง A N ลบ 1 โดยดึง เค
A ออกจากด้านหน้าเวกเตอร์ S0 ถึง S N ลบ 1 พลิกให้เป็น บรา A แทน
เค A แล้วแปะไว้ทางขวามือตามที่แสดงในสมการบนหน้าจอ วิธีหนึ่งในการคิดเรื่อง
นี้คือเราพับเวกเตอร์เหล่านี้เป็นเมทริกซ์ ถ้าเราซ้อนคอลัมน์ของ AK ทับกัน เราจะ
ได้ S กลับมา ดังนั้นเมทริกซ์เหล่านี้มีค่าเดียวกันกับเวกเตอร์ที่ตรงกัน แค่เรา
จัดเรียงค่าต่างกันเพื่อให้ได้เมทริกซ์ แต่เรายังคิดเกี่ยวกับเมทริกซ์เหล่านี้ในเชิงสัญลักษณ์ผ่านสัญกรณ์ Dirac ได้
ตามที่เขียนตรงนี้ และตอนนี้มีคำถามชัดๆ อยู่ว่าทำไมมันถึงใช้ได้ อย่าไปเจาะลึกมากเกินว่า
ทำไมมันใช้ได้ แค่ตรวจสอบว่ามันใช้ได้จริง เพื่อทำนี้ มากำหนดการแปลงใหม่ซึ่งเป็นการแปลงที่กำหนดโดย
เมทริกซ์เหล่านี้ที่เราใช้เป็นเมทริกซ์ Kraus สิ่งที่เราทำได้ตอนนี้คือคำนวณ Choi representation ของ
การแปลงใหม่นี้ แล้วเราจะเห็นว่ามันเท่ากับ Choi representation ของการแปลง ฟี ที่เราเริ่มต้น และ
เพราะ Choi representation เป็นแบบซื่อสัตย์ หมายความว่าสองการแปลงเท่ากันจริง ผมจะไม่ลงรายละเอียดพีชคณิตในวิดีโอนี้
ลองตรวจสอบเอง มันค่อนข้างเป็นกลไกและเป็นการฝึกที่ดี และทุกอย่างที่ต้องใช้
อยู่บนหน้าจอ เรายังไม่ได้พูดอะไรเกี่ยวกับเงื่อนไขที่สองในสองกล่อง แต่
มันปรากฏว่าเท่ากัน และวิธีหนึ่งที่จะแสดงคือตรวจสอบสมการที่แสดงตรงล่างของ
หน้าจอ ตัว T ตรงนี้หมายถึงการทรานสโพสเมทริกซ์ ซึ่งคุณอาจคิดว่าเป็น
การแปลงเชิงเส้นที่เปลี่ยน เค A บรา B เป็น เค B บรา A และเป็นแค่สิ่งที่จำเป็นเพื่อให้สูตรใช้ได้ ดังนั้น
สรุปแล้ว มีพีชคณิตที่ต้องทำสำหรับการอนุมานนี้ แต่อย่างที่บอก มันค่อนข้างเป็นกลไก
พื้นฐานคือการยิมนาสติกดัชนี ตามที่บางคนเรียกแบบนี้ แต่ถ้าลองทำดูและให้สมองย่อยมัน คุณอาจพบว่า
คุณออกมาด้วยความเข้าใจที่ดีขึ้นว่า Choi representation และ Kraus representation เกี่ยวข้องกันยังไง การอนุมานที่สามทำให้เรา
ไปจาก Kraus representation ของการแปลง ฟี ที่เงื่อนไขปกติเป็นไปตาม ไปยัง Stinespring representation อันนี้ค่อนข้าง
คล้ายจิตวิญญาณกับการอนุมานก่อนหน้าในแง่ที่มันเป็นกลไกและสามารถมองและตรวจสอบในแง่พีชคณิตล้วนๆ
ไอเดียค่อนข้างง่ายจริงๆ สิ่งที่เราทำได้คือเอาเมทริกซ์ Kraus มาสร้างส่วนหนึ่งของเมทริกซ์ที่ใหญ่กว่าโดยซ้อน
ทับกันตามที่แสดงบนหน้าจอ เมื่อเติมเต็มแล้ว นี่จะให้เมทริกซ์ unitary U สำหรับ
Stinespring representation เมทริกซ์ unitary ต้องเป็นเมทริกซ์จัตุรัส ดังนั้นเราต้องเติมคอลัมน์ที่เหลือ
อีกเท่าที่จำเป็น แต่ไม่สำคัญว่าจะเป็นอะไร ตราบใดที่ได้เมทริกซ์
unitary ถ้าเราพักเรื่อง U เป็น unitary ไว้ก่อน แล้วแค่ดูการแปลงเชิงเส้นที่กำหนดโดย
Stinespring representation ที่เราได้จากเมทริกซ์ U นี้ เราจะพบว่าการแปลงเท่ากับ
การแปลง ฟี เดิมที่กำหนดโดย Kraus representation ที่เราเริ่มต้น นั่นเป็นอีกส่วนของการพิสูจน์ที่ผมจะไม่ลงรายละเอียดในวิดีโอนี้
หารายละเอียดได้ในเนื้อหาที่เขียนของบทเรียนนี้ แต่คุณอาจอยากใช้เวลาทำด้วยตัวเอง แค่จำ
ไว้ตามปกติของซีรีส์ว่าเราใช้ธรรมเนียมลำดับ qubit ในการตีความไดอะแกรม ดังนั้น W และ G จะ
ตรงกับ tensor factor ทางซ้ายมือในสมการ แล้วก็ถ้าลอง
ทำดู จะพบว่าเพราะเรามี เค0 บรา 0 เป็น tensor factor ทางซ้ายในสมการ
ที่ต้องตรวจสอบ ส่วนเดียวของ U ที่เกี่ยวข้องคือส่วนที่กำหนดโดยเมทริกซ์ Kraus ดังนั้นตราบใดที่เรา
เติมคอลัมน์ของ U ให้มันเป็น unitary เราก็โอเค แต่แน่นอนว่าต้องการให้คอลัมน์ที่เกิดจาก A0 ถึง A N ลบ
1 เมื่อซ้อนกัน เป็นออร์โธนอร์มัล และตรงนี้เองที่เงื่อนไขที่เราวางบน Kraus representation มีบทบาท
และจริงๆ แล้วมันเท่ากับคอลัมน์เป็นออร์โธนอร์มัลพอดี ความสัมพันธ์ทางคณิตศาสตร์ที่เกี่ยวข้องที่จำเป็นสำหรับข้อสรุปนี้
แสดงตรงล่างของหน้าจอ ลองหยุดแล้วตรวจสอบถ้าต้องการ หรืออีกครั้ง
ดูเนื้อหาที่เขียนสำหรับรายละเอียดเพิ่มเติม สรุปสั้นๆ สิ่งที่เกิดขึ้นตรงนี้ทั้งในการอนุมานนี้และ
อันก่อนหน้าคือ เราอธิบายการดำเนินการทางคณิตศาสตร์เดียวกันในวิธีที่ต่างกันแต่เท่ากัน
หัวใจหลักของทั้งหมดคือการคูณเมทริกซ์ การอนุมานที่สี่และสุดท้ายแสดงว่าถ้าเรามี
Stinespring representation สำหรับการแปลงบางอย่าง การแปลงนั้นต้องเป็น channel ที่ถูกต้อง และอย่างที่บอก
ก่อนหน้า เราครอบคลุมการอนุมานนี้แล้วตอนที่พูดถึง Stinespring representation สรุปและ
พูดอีกแบบ การแนะนำระบบทำงานที่เริ่มต้นแล้วเป็น channel ที่ถูกต้อง เพราะการเทนเซอร์เมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นคงที่
กับเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นที่กำหนดจะให้เมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นเสมอ และเป็นการแปลงเชิงเส้นโดยความเป็นเชิงเส้นคู่
ของเทนเซอร์โปรดักต์ การดำเนินการ unitary เป็น channel ที่ถูกต้องเสมอ อย่างที่พูดไปก่อนหน้าในบทเรียน การเทรซระบบออกเป็น channel ที่ถูกต้อง เพราะ
partial trace เป็นการแปลงเชิงเส้นที่แปลงเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นเป็นเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นเสมอ และสุดท้าย การประกอบกันของ
channel ก็เป็น channel เสมอ ซึ่งค่อนข้างง่าย แต่ก็ควรสังเกตเป็นเรื่องของมัน และด้วย
การอนุมานทั้งสี่ที่เราครอบคลุมไป เราก็แสดงความเท่ากันของ representation ของ channel ทั้งสามแบบพร้อมกับ
นิยามเดิมของ channel โดยเฉพาะเราเริ่มจากนิยามของ channel เราเห็นว่านิยามนั้นอนุมานได้ว่า Choi
representation ต้องเป็นไปตามสองเงื่อนไขพื้นฐาน จากนั้นเราเห็นว่าเงื่อนไขเหล่านั้นทำให้เราหา Kraus representation ซึ่งในทางกลับกัน
ทำให้เราหา Stinespring representation ได้ และสุดท้ายเราเห็นว่าการมี Stinespring representation เผยว่าเรา
มี channel ที่ถูกต้องจริง แน่นอนมีรายละเอียดทางเทคนิคอยู่ และมันไม่จำเป็นต้องง่าย โดยเฉพาะ
เมื่อเห็นครั้งแรก แต่สิ่งที่น่าสนใจและน่าสังเกตตรงนี้คือ การอนุมานเหล่านี้ถูกจัดตั้งในแบบที่ทำให้
สิ่งต่างๆ ง่ายที่สุดเท่าที่จะเป็นไปได้ และในคณิตศาสตร์ คุณไม่ควรอายที่จะเลือกทางง่ายเลย
เช่น มันไม่ชัดเจนเลยว่าทุก channel มี Stinespring representation หรือ Kraus representation
แต่มันค่อนข้างง่ายที่จะสรุปว่า Choi representation ของทุก channel เป็นไปตามสองเงื่อนไขที่เราเชื่อมโยงกับมัน และนั่น
ทำให้เราตามเส้นทางพีชคณิตไปยังอีกสอง representation ได้ ในทำนองเดียวกัน
การอนุมานสุดท้ายจาก Stinespring representation กลับไปที่นิยามก็ค่อนข้างตรงไปตรงมาเช่นกัน และ
ทำให้เราสรุปได้ว่าเราได้แค่ channel เท่านั้นและไม่มีการแปลงอื่นจาก Choi representation โดยสมมติว่า
เงื่อนไขที่ต้องการเป็นไปตาม และอย่างที่พูดไป วิธีที่เราให้เหตุผลการอนุมานเหล่านี้เป็นกลไกเพียงพอที่จะทำให้เราแปลง
ระหว่าง representation ได้ง่าย และถ้ากลับไปดูตัวอย่างที่เราครอบคลุมก่อนหน้าในบทเรียน จะพบว่าเป็นไปได้จริงที่จะ
แปลงระหว่าง representation บางทีก็ค่อนข้างง่ายและตรงไปตรงมา และนั่นคือจบ
บทเรียน ซึ่งเป็นเรื่องของ channel ทั้งหมด เราพูดถึงว่ามันคืออะไรและดูตัวอย่างพื้นฐาน เราพูดถึงสามวิธีที่ channel สามารถ
ถูกแทนได้ และเราลงลึกรายละเอียดทางเทคนิคที่แสดงความเท่ากันของ representation เหล่านี้
หวังว่าจะมาร่วมบทเรียนถัดไปที่เกี่ยวกับการวัดผลในสูตรทั่วไปของข้อมูลควอนตัม ลาก่อน แล้วเจอกัน